think women are bad with money I don't
think women are bad with money
Yeah by and large our gender doesn't do
great I'm already yeah they're easier
the influenced by the by social
conditioning adverts social media and
everything that's going on I don't think
it's easily info
and for saying earlier women are the
focal
ads now are being pointed towards women
and so but why they're buying more
things well why because I think it's no
more women are in the workforce and more
women
because yo it's because the brands know
exactly why because they know they can
influence you want your biggest Spenders
and you you know that great with you can
be easily swayed to have the what's the
word
impulse buys all right I can I can give
you I I have it broken down don't worry
guys don't think all right a study by a
com ment guys whose phone whose phone is
this
um okay a study by a company called
family financial showed that the average
woman spends
I think I said this earlier
526
374 dollars more than the average man in
her lifetime breakdown is as follows
okay I'm gonna give you guys the the one
two threes four five the six things and
I'm just gonna have you guys vote on on
what you think the women spend the most
on okay there's personal care products
home ownership feminine products
clothing beauty products and health care
who here thinks that personal care
products
is the mouse from women's
yeah I think that's Beauty
okay so who here thinks it's personal
care products you two do okay two two
okay
um home ownership who thinks that's what
women spend money on I want it to be
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
okay all right feminine care products
you know we talk about the tampon tax
anyone feminine care no okay yeah we
know
um clothing
you guys think clothing you guys think
clothing okay okay beauty products and
everyone's okay they're changing beauty
products Healthcare yeah we talk about
women giving birth and [ __ ] who says
that is very expensive all right
actually I double vote okay well I'll
I'll just let you do that
the number one thing that women spend on
in a lifetime is beauty products
three hundred thousand dollars more than
men yeah
I'm not surprised number two personal
care products a hundred and thirty two
thousand dollars more
um number three Health Care sixty six
thousand nine hundred and fifty four
dollars
um home ownership it's like I can't
believe home ownership one of the last
ones
um but it's on the list twenty girl not
by twenty four thousand dollars in a
lifetime
extra money you know what I was I
feminine care products 1920 I was proud
of us for clothing that was last a
thousand five hundred yeah have you seen
have you seen this have you seen what
girls wear nowadays it's like
a little bit oh yeah
so much there to pay for well I just
think there's like [ __ ] like there's
such fast fashion yeah it's like cheap
we're trying to get one away from Fast
fashion you guys okay go ahead yeah I
just wanted to uh go back to the
previous question of why women spend
more uh I also think it's because of
women that have this Hive mindset they
they think like if if her friend is have
like uh the latest iPhone she also wants
the the iPhone if the other girl has I
don't know uh Balenciaga shoes she also
owns that while men are more uh
analytical and more critical when
thinking why should I spend on I don't
know something that's not gonna give me
value in the future that's gonna you
know um
uh give a good Roi so I that's what I
think and then spend so much money on
video games no no I think I think
subconsciously women women want to
believe that somebody's going to take
care of them yeah so they can be more
frivolous
you know what's interesting this happens
a lot whenever we talk about something
about women like we always feel the need
to say but man okay but women do they do
the same thing you're like what no but
if it's if it's okay okay can we can we
disagree like if we spend half a million
dollar more dollars more in a lifetime
300 000 in a Lifetime on beauty products
that maybe we have a problem I mean but
we just had this whole what two-hour
conversation about what men value
without having conversation like beauty
is the number one thing yeah that's true
I mean there's the there's a correlation
there's a correlation right it's
definitely correlation
could you argue that then women want
attention from men and that's the number
one thing they want if that's the number
one thing they spend on I think you can
make that argument I wouldn't say that's
I wouldn't say that's true and they want
to compete with other women as well
you could say you could say women don't
you could say women don't dress for if
you're going to blame the men for like
like that being why we spend it on it
then you can't say women dress for
ourselves no I'm not saying we blame I'm
not there's no blaming here I just think
that this that we need to like think
about these things like from a bird's
eye view like there's like we were
having these conversations about like
how what influences behavior and I think
that when we talk about spending habits
that should be a part of the
conversation as well like I know a lot
of my like same thing like I do it for
the girlies like we always like get like
all the outfits that we wear like I
don't think that men really care how our
our clothes match or not okay so so we
spend money on beauty products for
ourselves I think it's I think it's I
think it's both I think like I want to
feel like 50 50. let's call it 50. okay
50 50. or maybe I'm wrong like but but
we can go but like we like we like a
well a nicely dressed man like I think a
guy that's dressed well like a suit I
think a suit gives a guy like at least a
point like you ever go to like a school
dance and you're like I didn't even know
he was cute
and I don't know when you're a kid high
school yeah you you what I was
homeschooled oh you're homeschooled
that's so cool for like I went to high
school but I was homeschooled for most
of it but um but they don't spend for
like frivolously like we do so like we
have a problem you know as women we
spend more we're not as good with money
even though we make less like we make
ten thousand dollars less than men or it
pounds to I don't know
and yet we spend more I think he's been
raising his hand yeah go ahead oh oh so
hey thank you
um I have a theory and it went kind of
so before uh women I believe would wear
makeup to attract the male uh the
attention of men
um but I think as time's going on I
think girls more wear makeup to one-up
each other that's what that's what it
feels like it feels like girls are not
wearing makeup to one of each other
which makes the statement I don't dress
for men I dress for myself more relevant
but at the same time the the men come
with that do you see what I'm saying I'm
sorry
um so we kind of have that thing where
girls will get all dressed up wear very
revealing stuff tight form-fitting
things makeup done hair nails done but
then like we were saying as well going
for the top but only when the top
mail comes to you will you show a man
attention everybody else is kind of out
of it because you and your girls are
just trying to outdo each other right
and that's kind of what it as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible